le sourire aux lèvres le professeur
jacquard concentre une nouvelle fois ses
bâtiments toujours étonné par leur
énorme superficie le sourire aux lèvres
car satisfait des sursauts que ce coup
de force a provoqué
c'est à la fois une victoire et une
petite phrase qu'il va falloir
surveiller je ne doute pas de la bonne
volonté ce monsieur zappia sûr et s'il
l'a dit c'est qu'il le croit et
maintenant il faut qu'ils agissent alors
on va voir si ça dépend vraiment de lui
il va y avoir des problèmes entre bien
sûr les autorités municipales les
autorités préfectorales
mais ça ça les concerne c'est tout
nouveau squat au coeur de saint germain
semble déjà populaire le contact avec
les riverains et les passants va bon
train et de matériel pas si aide
financière par là ou simples signatures
de soutien
je passe tous les matins là et je trouve
ça dommage qu'ils aient un immeuble vide
je pense qu'il faut l'occuper c'est une
manière ou d'une autre à l'intérieur la
vie s'organise avec les moyens du bord
cette famille expulsés depuis six mois
et rendent foyer en foyer depuis a passé
sa première nuit dans un deux pièces en
parfait état
plus de 50 logements sont dans le même
cas
le fait d'avoir ça me dire en toi et
d'avoir ça veut dire des gens qui
pensent à nous ça c'est merveilleux
alors on al impression qu nato et ce
nouvel espace de limites m chiari cible
d'une opération immobilière de la
progérine les nouveaux occupants ne
veulent pas le quitter à moins d'être
relogés pourquoi pas imaginer qu'on
mettrait cet immeuble à notre
disposition pour les familles au nom de
la solidarité au nom d'un d'une certaine
citoyenneté aussi je pense que c'est
possible pour l'instant silence radio de
la cogedim
le grand promoteur immobilier contacté
depuis ce matin ne s'est pas prononcé